All right, Drew, we have an iconic piece
of American pop culture at this desk right now.
Look at this, the ThighMaster!
(audience cheering)
Right?
Oh my god, it's harder than I remember it being.
Like that's a lot of resistance.
Yeah, well, you remember these.
You guys, you remember you couldn't swing a fish
without hitting these in the '90s.
Swing a fish?
Uh huh.
I thought it was swing a cat.
Whatever.
Oh my god, I mean, now I'm really
like going for the clown thing.
Yeah, honk-honk.
It just got worse.
Okay, let's try.
Okay, let's sit and I'll tell the story.
Okay.
Okay, ooh, whew, that burns.
Ooh, ooh, okay.
Well, "People" report Suzanne Somers just revealed
how much she actually made on her ThighMaster empire.
Here's her quote, she said,
"They were 19.95 times 10 million, you do the math,"
and then actually it's 15 million of these were sold.
And that adds up to about $300 million, you guys.
(audience clapping)
Ooh, that's really does do something though.
I mean, I'm gonna have to...
I know, my body is sort of in shock right now
that I'm paying attention to it.
Can I stop?
I love her, ouch, so much.
Wait, wait, what?
Oh my god!
Wait a minute!
(audience cheering)
Is that real?
Is she moving?
Are you really there?
That's really her.
Look she blinked!
Oh my gosh!
Oh my god!
It's Suzanne Somers!
Suzanne Somers!
(audience cheering)
Hi there.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Be careful!
Be careful with the way you have it
between your knees, Ross, you'll be a soprano.
Is it pointed the right way?
No, you could hurt yourself.
That is so funny.
Turn it around.
Oh my god, this is so weird that you're here.
I can't even, okay, let's act like this.
Oh my god, Suzanne Somers.
That's the way!
Oh, that's easier now.
That's better.
Yeah, yeah.
I love you so much.
Thank you.
You are such a national treasure.
I'm so excited to be talking to you right now.
I can't believe it.
I had no idea.
Also, not only have you brought so much like depth
to Chrissy Snow and comedy and effervescence,
but you are one smart businesswoman.
Hello, hello!
Okay, but what you said about the money,
there were a lot of expenses.
You had to have them manufactured,
shipped, developed, well, you know.
So it sounds better than it is, but I did great.
And it was kind of a na-na, na-na, na-na for me,
because I don't know if you recall,
but they always said she left the show.
I didn't leave the show, I was fired,
because my contract was up and I was asked,
all the men were being paid 10 to 15 times more than me.
So I went in and said, "I'd like you to pay me
what you're paying the men."
And they fired me so that no other woman would (indistinct).
(audience cheering)
So I showed them!
And then, look what you did.
Yeah.
You know, I love that.
You never let anyone underestimate you.
And if they do, you show them with $300 million
is what you do and changing the world.
Yeah.
Thank you, thank you.
I mean, what gave you like the idea
or the path to take this on?
Because you've definitely been really early
to the health and wellness game far before it was on trend.
And was it always something
that you were passionate about in your life?
Here's what I've learned.
I celebrate my age, I'm 75 now and I love being 75.
I'll tell you, here's what I learned,
the worst things in your life can work for you
if you choose it, like judo, using forward energy to win.
So, you know, being fired,
I then started as an entrepreneur and did really well.
And it was all because I bought a pair
of Manolo Blahnik shoes that were almost $600 and I thought,
"Oh, Alan's gonna think I'm so stupid."
And I was in my bra and underpants
and I put them on and I walked out of my dressing room,
said to Alan in my bra and underpants, "Like my new shoes?"
And those ended up being the shoes
that I wore in the commercial,
which I then got to write off 'cause they were free.
And they panned up my legs and Alan said, "Great legs,"
and that's how that began.
Wow!
I mean, I also wanna ask
you one last question, Suzanne.
Is it true that when you were getting,
you know, different sort of business opportunities
what is it that you can suggest to us
so we may take your wisdom?
You keep betting on yourself.
Mmm.
What is your advice to us?
You can't be yes.
Like right now, you know, with all the books,
I've written 27 books,
and all about health and being a child of an alcoholic,
and all these things.
But when I was telling people
the terrible effects of chemicals on our body
that's been introduced in our lifetimes,
and you can see the epidemic of sickness and disease
commensurate with the chemicals,
so I developed a line of organic cosmetics,
organic skincare, lead-free lipstick,
household cleaning products.
You can get them at: suzannesomers.com.
And I can sell it, 'cause I totally believe in it.
I think it's crazy to put chemical creams
on your hands and arms, or face or body,
and then have it drip into your bloodstream,
and then end up in GI track
and everybody's got gut problems.
Oh, by the way, I have a thing called Gut Renew.
Right there.
Right there, which is so popular,
it's rivaling the ThighMaster right now.
I order it in lots of like 70 tons at a time.
So I just kind of go with the flow,
listen to what the people say,
listen to what my gut says and I've done real well with it.
And I also have a partner, my husband,
Alan Hamel, who I just adore.
We've been together 54 years now.
Aw!
Wow!
(upbeat music)